[Music]
hi everyone I'm Sabra swallows and I'm a
researcher Microsoft Research in Redmond
and today I will be talking about our
project on confidential AI so in this
project we want to enable confidential
machine learning in the cloud and as we
all know most of the training today
happens on accelerators such as GPUs or
other custom silicon so while we know
that CPU vendors have been designing
trusts execution environments to provide
the grantees to cloud users that their
code and data are being isolated from
the entire system start we there is no
any support today in today's
accelerators so in this project where we
seek to design trust execution
environments on accelerators such as
GPUs so in our vision is that we want to
enable trusted applications running on
trusted CPU on trusted CPUs to offload
securely code and data to the GPU or any
other accelerator while providing strong
isolation and protection against
compromised OS and hypervisor so our
goal here is that is to minimize the
changes that need to go to the to the
trust to the GPU so we can basically
enable this design with low cost so here
we have a demo so we're basically having
two systems were basically what doing
training on top of a caffè framework of
a deep neural network so here I plot two
two systems one system is basically the
baseline system which is vulnerable to
attacks by
and malicious adversary well the other
system has all the confidential
communities we have introduced in this
project allowing for strong protection I
guess this attacks so here we're
demonstrating one at one particular
attack which allows people to steal
images or compromised code and data as
they're copied into device memory as we
can show here we can basically provide
authentic encryption of all the traffic
going into device memory while providing
strong isolation of that memory region
from the rest of the staff at minimal
performance cost so we show that even if
we build this on on a prototype we build
our program on commodity GPUs where we
are mutilate the new hardware changes in
the device driver and we show that even
with conservative performance estimates
our slowdown is less than 30% so we
believe that with the high right
hardware support by GPU vendors will be
able to deliver trust execution
environments on GPUs with low
performance cost thank you
[Music]
you